Netflix's that 90s show is a true to
form sitcom Revival aimed at nostalgic
Millennials and their 90s loving teens
while there's no thorny plot to untangle
there's still plenty of groovy allusions
to That 70s Show to unpack what made
That 70s Show so special was The
Chemistry Between the ensemble cast
unknown actors who were launched into
stardom thanks to their time on the show
their Dynamic worked so well that it was
essentially replicated for the new
generation of teens in that 90s show in
episode 1 that 90s pilot Topher Grace
and Laura Prepon reprized their roles as
Eric and Donna now parents to 14 year
old Leia and living in Chicago Donna is
a published author and Eric teaches a
college course about the religion of
Star Wars both fitting career paths for
the two lovebirds their supportive
parenting Styles also go hand in hand
Donna is proud of her daughter and
encourages her to find herself while
Eric has a harder time letting go of his
little girl listen pal in the space of
one day you've gotten pierced you've
gotten beer and you've gotten extremely
snippy
real life couple Ashton Kutcher and Mila
Kunis are also back reprising their
roles of Kelso and Jackie whose son Jay
befriends Leia the two are preparing for
their second remarriage Wilmer
Valderrama is also back as Fez who is
revealed to be kooky next door neighbor
Sherry's love interest in episode 2 free
Leia as for Danny Masterson his
character Hyde is ignored due to
Masterson's public legal trouble
two more familiar faces from the
original cast have reprized their roles
as recurring characters in that 90s show
and their presence makes us feel right
at home one of the best grumpy Sunshine
Duos in sitcom history red and kitty
Foreman are leading characters just as
much as their teenage counterparts if
not more instead of being thrown into a
sequel with an all-new cast red and
kitty ground Us in the familiar red is
still putting his foot in people's asses
and kitty is still ensuring the kids are
well fed they were the parents who
shaped a generation and now they're the
grandparents for a new generation the
original teens now adults look back at
their teen Hood in the foreman house
with fondness while the new teens feel
welcomed instantly in episode 2 free
Leia one of the kids Nate feels
comfortable enough to ask red for one of
his hip flannels from his vast
collection it's the 90s after all red
turns him away but don't be fooled by
his hard exterior by the end of the
episode Red makes a silent gesture by
leaving a flannel for Nate and his van
can I call you Uncle Ed
in episode 5 step by step another kid
Ozzy helps Kitty set up her new computer
hoping they'll form a bond strong enough
for Kitty to accept Ozzy's coming out
announcement it's no surprise the kitty
Embraces him with open arms
meet the newest Foreman Leia if you
haven't already picked up on it yet yes
she was named after Princess Leia thanks
to Eric's Star Wars Obsession she's a
straight-edged insecure teen ready to
make the most out of her life she's
tired of being an unpopular debate nerd
and wants to spend the summer
cultivating the same experiences her
parents fondly reminisce about instead
Eric is eager for her to join him during
a summer long space camp it seems as
though there's no way of getting out of
it until she meets rebellious Riot Girl
Gwen who acts as a catalyst for Leia
after some convincing Leia is granted
permission to stay with her grandparents
for the summer where Gwen will introduce
her to a new group of friends Leia
desperately wants to fit in in her eyes
these cool and experienced teens won't
want anything to do with her when they
realize she's a fraud in episode 2 free
Leia after failing to host a fun movie
night Leia lets her insecurities get the
best of her Gwen reassured is Leia that
her friends aren't interested in how
cool or uncool she is and would rather
she be her most authentic self by
episode 3 lip smackers Leia gains enough
confidence to initiate her first kiss a
big step towards Leia becoming
comfortable in her own skin
in episode 1 that 90s pilot Leia may not
know it yet but friendship will become
her biggest confidence booster
everything changes when Gwen introduces
Leia to her dim-witted but kind-hearted
brother Nate his girlfriend Nikki the
sarcastic quick-witted Ozzy and Leia's
flirty love interest J each of these
characters somewhat follow the
archetypes of the original personalities
Gwen takes on aspects of Donna and
Hyde's personalities Nate and Jay are
both reminiscent of Kelso Nikki will
remind you of Jackie Ozzy is the new Fez
and Leia obviously takes after her
father history is repeating itself which
will either feel comforting for some or
lazily repetitive for others depending
on the viewer as the series tagline
States times change teenagers don't
although Leia may be the new kid on the
Block everyone in the group is still
getting to know each other Nate and Jay
are already the closest out of everyone
swapping cologne and sharing ice cream
cones Gwen and Nikki bond for the first
time in episode 5 step by step when
they're left alone with each other in
episode 8 summer storm Gwen and Nate
grow closer as siblings when they open
up about missing their dads by the
season finale the teens are closer than
ever
set in 1995 that 90s show takes place 15
years after the 2006 finale of that 70
show when the teens rang in the new
decade of the 80s when That 70s Show
premiered to audiences in 1998 many
viewers were reliving their teen Hood
from the late 70s while teens of the 90s
were fascinated by the novelty of the
time period with the perfect 15-year
time Jump new and old audiences can
enjoy the sequel in the same way like
the original that 90s show captures its
time periods culture using references to
Fashion music and historical events as
well as tackling timely social issues in
some of the episodes storylines some
references sprinkled into the show
include Gwen's interest in the riot Girl
Movement Leia's favorite movie Free
Willy and a Beverly Hills 90210 themed
episode where Brian Austin Green makes a
cameo no one came to watch me DJ at the
Peach Pit not even Donna Martin
the worst the teens also spend some time
at a video rental store a rave and a
bustling Mall while all this may seem
normal to Millennial viewers gen Z
likely regards these as retro references
at least the ones that don't fly right
over their heads
it wouldn't be a teen sitcom without
Bromance and For Better or Worse season
one of that 90s show spins a big chunk
of its run time on the budding
relationship between Leia and Jay right
away Jay is introduced as the smooth
talking flirt who takes a liking to Leia
like the good friend she is Gwen warns
Leia about Jay's reputation as a player
but when Jay turns down Leia's attempt
to kiss him in episode 3 lip smackers
Leia can't help but obsess over Jay's
comments about how he wants their
relationship to be more than just a
meaningless hookup the two go back and
forth in The Following episode refusing
to be the first to make a move despite
already knowing their feelings for each
other its typical teen relationship
drama that leaves them in a fight at the
end of the episode but don't worry the
two make up by episode 6 and officially
start dating too bad we only have four
more episodes before the summer ends
fast forward to the season one finale
and Jay is ready to break things off not
wanting to try long distance during a
vulnerable moment Leia and Nate open up
to each other about heartbreak and love
a conversation that almost ends with a
kiss
adolescence identity and coming of age
are major themes throughout that 90s
show the teens are rebelling trying new
things and figuring themselves out along
the way remind you of anyone of course
these are the Growing Pains of every
generation and if there is one guarantee
in any of this it's that mistakes will
be made in episode 4 Rave Leia tells her
first big lie by tricking her
grandparents into thinking she's going
to see a movie when she's really seeking
off to a rave she's caught at the end
and taught a lesson about taking
advantage of trust and love but how
often do teens learn their lesson the
first time in episode 7 boyfriend day
one Jay Leia and Gwen pick up a drugged
Kitty from her dentist appointment
despite Red's strict demands that Leia
and Jay keep away from each other while
trying to prove how responsible they can
be they take a detour to a tattoo shop
where Kitty ends up getting some new ink
cue the thing about trust and love again
however the biggest lesson Leia learns
this summer happens in episode 6 the
birthday girl when red pulls her aside
during her birthday party and initiates
a heart to heart Leia comes clean about
what's been bothering her she feels as
though she has no idea what she's doing
and keeps messing everything up at that
moment red bestows upon her wisdom that
encapsulates the whole show we're all
just making it up as we go along
something unique about that 90s show
that sets it apart from other teen
sitcoms is its inclusion of the parents
perspective rarely do teen shows take an
empathetic approach towards parental
figures by showcasing healthy
parent-child relationships in that 90s
show these relationships are more than
just mother father and child while Leia
is under the guardianship of her
grandparents for the summer they take on
the roles of caregiver and supporter red
and kitty are protective of Leia but
trust her enough to make her own
decisions episode 8 summer storm
highlights a different yet very common
kind of Parental relationship Sherry is
the single mother of Gwen and Nate
half-siblings with different fathers
Gwen and nape don't always see eye to
eye but during a touching moment the
siblings open up about missing their
fathers Kitty joins in revealing a peek
into her own daddy issues in episode 7
boyfriend day one Sherry's paternal
angst is also revealed when red starts
reminding her of her father in a rare
sweet red moment he even offers to help
Sherry learn how to ride a bike
something her father never did for her
that 90s show feels like one big
throwback from its 90s era Nostalgia to
its not so subtle nods to the original
even if you've never seen that 70s Show
it's possible to watch this new
iteration and enjoy it however most of
the fun comes from picking up on all the
That 70s Show Easter eggs with fond
memories of the original significant
moments pack an even greater punch like
when red gifts Leia the Vista Cruiser or
when the new teens reenact the memorable
smoke Circle scenes how many times do
you turn 15 in your life
not that many
memorable catchphrases like Red's foot
in the ass and Kelso's damn Jackie are
all the more funny the foreman house we
know and love is untouched from its
Dusty basement couch to the kitchen
knickknacks even the transitions between
scenes take after the style of the
original even if you're just looking for
a trip down memory lane that 90s show is
worth a watch
season one ends with a finale entitled
Kids In America granted a song that
technically came out in the 1980s but a
90s Anthem nonetheless summer is coming
to an end and to make things worse Jay
breaks up with Leia causing Gwen and
Leia to fight now Leia can't get out of
Point Place fast enough kitty tries
everything she can to remind Leia of the
good times to ensure she returns next
summer in the end Gwen and Leia make up
and Jay asks Leia to give him another
chance but Leia has mixed feelings after
almost kissing Nate setting us up for a
juicy season 2 love triangle for now
we're left with Leia saying her goodbyes
as of the Season 1 premiere Netflix has
yet to announce a renewal for season two
but with mostly positive reviews so far
there's still a good chance that we'll
return to Point Place for the summer of
96.
[Music]